Ромео і Джульєтта на новий лад.
Вона киянка, він із Севастополя.
У неї проукраїнські погляди,
у нього - проросійські.
Це чергова порція російської пропаганди -
фільм "Крим". Суміш любовної історії
і воєнної драми, в якій
Росія постає як визволитель.
Новий російський фільм обійшовся
у майже 7 мільйонів доларів,
профінансувало його Міністерство оборони РФ.
Втім, ані історія кохання,
ані спецефекти, ані патріотичні мотиви,
схоже, не справили враження
на російських кіноманів.
Хакерам навіть довелося штучно
накручувати її рейтинг на ресурсі "Кинопоиск".
І поки федеральні ЗМІ повідомляють про те,
що стрічка побила усі касові рекорди,
у Санкт-Петербурзі та інших великих містах країни
фільм зустріли напівпорожні зали.
Навіть на вечірні сеанси
подекуди не викуплено жодного квитка.
Це спричинило хвилю глузувань у соцмережах -
пропагандистську стрічку
висміяли навіть самі росіяни.
Анексія Криму - друга за популярністю тема
у російських пропагандистів.
До першої річниці, як вони це називають,
повернення півострова, зняли фільм
"Крим. Шлях на Батьківщину" -
блокбастер, в якому Володимир Путін
детально розповів свою версію того,
як відбувалася анексія.
А от на першому місці за популярністю
у російських пропагандистів -
незмінно перемога СРСР у Другій світовій війні.
На виробництво пропагандистських стрічок
Росія витрачає мільйони рублів,
намагаючись грати на почуттях громадян.
Особливо це актуально
напередодні президентських виборів,
які відбудуться у березні 2018 року.